I like to test things it's my favorite
thing to do also it's my job so I don't
know what to say to you I don't think I
need you just buy anything that I do
beat mines I don't look at me that way I
am a man of principle
don't you think I have a large
collection of awards from many different
organisms hello welcome back to mr.
Musashi my eternal lesson in to tell you
how not to behave not only around girls
but any human being and just generally
not be me cool great I'm gonna do that
intro again because that's up you okay
with that I'll be right back hello
everybody my name is markiplier this is
definitely the first time that I've said
that I'm still going with this one so
welcome to mr. Musashi now I'm going to
tell you exactly how to not do the thing
where you talk to people and interact
with humans because obviously I'm not an
expert on but I've got four people or
animals apparently it doesn't matter but
I've got four people on this website
that I need to meet state I don't know
what you'd call it but I need to get to
know them and I think an but again I see
living people okay so does that just
mean that as long as I'm alive you're
okay with it
okay I'm
[Music]
I'm just gonna go with I don't know what
I'm doing with my life anymore I need a
hug
can you give me a hug hey it's a match I
guess it really doesn't matter it's
about what's inside and so long as
inside is a feeding heart literally no
other qualifications apply 95 percent of
phone users text things they could never
say in person the other 5% of
psychopaths okay that's weird
Johnny arrived at the pointy ghost rock
beach it's suddenly very very cold oh
it's a ghost isn't it oh hey hey how you
doing hey dude over here what's up are
you Johnny my lingered a my name's Anne
code we don't have here zoinks oh okay
hi I see you're glowing
hello why all the likes arching my
Sunstream what a radiant sauna this is
like look at a tubular wave makes you
want to dip in the ocean and be all
couch know what I'm saying hey you don't
need to explain couch to me I could
alone at home every night anyway uh
you're looking at me all funny and stuff
let's get this out of the way first
I'm a ghost no duh right so like don't
go like freaking out too much dude hey
it's good it's all good hey that chill
down my spine that's love baby and I'm
feeling it strong and hot and heavy you
want to go I don't know what we can do
but you want to go do that thing where
we explode ectoplasm all over each other
cuz that's got it okay nice never judge
anyone based on their looks a 300 heck
yeah I forgot my massaging massager
awesome you staying
gotta love out totally cool headed you
are hey if there's one thing that people
talked about markiplier if they talked
about my head a lot cuz it's gigantic
welcome to pointy ghost Rock Beach dude
people say it's haunted
woo you have like your idea how hard it
is to possess a phone and get a day just
slowly reach for the cross around your
neck you can possess up oh I know you
mean you can possess stuff
yeah when I first found out I was like
whoa know what I mean
ha totally do there's one thing the
markiplier knows about it's lying now
it's all like whatever man sort of lost
its luster
if anyway I'd rather not talk about my
dead woman stuff catch my drift tell me
like something about you dude can you
fly
oh well sorta no come on man I want to
know about you can go strip ah ah
pertinent want to feel my pecs oh no
damn it Johnny mysteriously blacked out
well I knew that wasn't gonna be good
but I just I'm ready for love you ready
for love I'm ready I'm ready I'm ready
I'm ready I'm never gotcha
oh yeah never judge uh I know what you
mean oh yeah really that's awesome like
you just take a phone right and then you
people slam get paired with some doofus
on linger hey wait a minute
I've been my way around linger a few
times a night
I think I'd consider myself a doofus
don't mind me as I hold a controller to
my neck like I kind of feel you just get
me you know I so totally feel like we're
totally getting along tell me like
something about you ah how can you touch
stuff I don't know man with practice I
guess no come on I want to know about
you can go strip can there is this a
date or like some shacho for you do cuz
I'm hella pissed right now
sorry I just really want to get to know
you I just want to get to know you
oh don't say that doofus it's all good
so are we gonna do something fun today
excuse me I need to put this under my
pit because
I'm weird I'm open to anything you want
wanna stay and chat until the Sun Goes
Down hey yeah you and me you and me
talking that's cool
hey if I ever got to meet a ghost I'd
wanna talk to it oh that's this we
boring his helmet sweet I guess I am
limited to places I can go I guess like
this one have fun today
that's so long since I've hung out with
someone my last date was pretty fly for
a blind girl she was always tripping
oh that's dark oh my god we've killed
him so he'll though she invited me to
her crib - goodness too bad she got
rough
hey totally uncool like fulfillment
Brandon who knows how long you dude you
like gonna get run over and just leave
me all alone oh hell no baby no car can
stand up to the marking new baby I mean
cars don't stand if I do end dial look
for you sugar plasma
I better go with that one oh we get run
over by your love baby nothing's weird
oh yeah that's good pit massage and then
we can like totally be together forever
I'm sweet I'll hold you to that promise
that's a little sudden okay you're
talking about some at the real eternal
marriage here and I don't know if I'm
ready for that I'm on linger just so you
know get to know people and meet
interesting new people I don't know if
I'm I don't know if I'm ready for a
commitment like death let's go get this
show on the road Jung Woo I did it me
wanker Oh also you guys wanted to know a
little bit of the relaxation therapy
that's going on here so I don't know if
that sounds good
got getting a that
then you get it feeling that am i
interrupting your love god with my boy
it's tell me if the stream is bothering
it stops but only will you tell me to
I'm gonna I'm gonna put an end to this
goddamn terrifying alright well that
worked out yeah there's only three to go
I got bad on the first try
what are you talking about me failing
that never happens I get things on the
first try
alright Popeye happy guy
hey there I'm just using linger oh my
it's a match hey come on pop you I you I
want to get to know you I want to get to
know you as a person
our friends came from the
english-speaking world is called an
English kiss in France is that true
French people is that true alright
oh no this is real
sometimes I feel like you the only one
that understands me Papa yeah this woman
for you you know a really beautiful for
oh I sure I was that to Babu let's start
this a real day I am oh boy are you a
pill okay this wasn't for my favor how
do you sleep you sleep and just smash
your face into the bed that's weird
alright I pop you I my name is
markiplier nice to meet you ah so you
are a hey baby are you a sailor ah yeah
[ __ ] I'll never get a girlfriend if
I keep playing this [ __ ] with the stupid
pillow well that doesn't seem logical at
all I don't think anybody should adhere
to that Oh Papa John you so funny oh
yeah I know I like the way you look at
my PEC eyes totally down there
oh my god I do CrossFit oh hell yeah
I'll get a beer for you to get two beers
you only found a grass of requests of
fresh milk in a jar mail though geez
okay don't take it well excuse me excuse
me for not having all the wonderful
things in the world for you papi why you
how can we do why don't we treat each
other with respect
do I feel about you right Bobby rise
are you talking to me now my earring
voice is in my head
he's real I'm not ever sent here if I'm
okay with it
thanks Babu I I needed to hear that
Levite you girl after all I only ever
wanted to have a family rule I didn't
know you wanted to pursue your career
first okay your career of sailing of
course I do want you to have a diploma
Oh another guy would you ever in your
entire pillow life would you don't tell
me anything that's a lie
what why you've been cheating on me I
got fully trust you
this is that you know about children I
actually wanted AB kid before 30 look I
don't want to discuss this Oh time we've
been here already
yeah it's business you can say without
by whoa what the hell what the hell did
happen okay you know what let's let's go
about this a different way I'm not sure
if this is normal you're always right
this is totally normal
you're welcome just want to squeeze the
feather Cuddy come on I'm just getting
too old
apparently I'm apparently I don't know
how to flirt with them all right let's
do for real I'm Johnny you are so
totally so funny
I still down there baby y'all get a beer
for you I'll buy a wine & caviar how do
we do this to each other know I love you
baby
thanks I needed to do that only whatever
why the family career all right happens
llama then oh I'm not worried about you
needing people I mean it's your dream
I'll always support you I'll be waiting
for you here if you sail the ocean and
me what what about it
oh I dream I don't know I just talking
to a camera all day long every day pokes
them on a weird website I don't even
know who's watching a few fields don't
load ilysm I've one more I can't be
happy with just i how i was what i have
when i where i can't just be happy gotta
keep moving forward no matter how scary
you totally said it so so inspiring babe
you can't be you can't be Oh boom
oh you know bad little world love you
how are you you might just crack a fat
tonight that mean what does that mean
use the sticks of the controller oh well
you can see the wobble on that bad boy
oh that's a wobble all right oh look at
that wob
that's what I'm looking for oh hell yeah
okay I'm out of here this weird okay
only two more to go let's get to it then
a screw you
alright Navia see I'm looking for my big
fairytale King are you him hashtag big
so are you like a giant he's like a
giant I'm a winner hailed as a king baby
oh hell yeah you like each other I know
I already liked her before I even knew
who she was
that's how avoided up the boys emotions
I am during the 30s Hollywood actors
were not allowed to kiss for longer than
three seconds
oh I don't see a problem with that I've
never done that in my life it's 3:00
a.m. Johnny's in the forest cold waiting
for Nadya to show up it's a magical
sensation oh wow okay
you are way way way bigger than I
expected
don't worry get that all the time don't
worry about it I'm not no one's ever
said that to me sorry I get kid away for
a second I tend to do that oh geez I
forgot to introduce myself
um right uh hi my name is Nadya I'm a
sworn protector of the forest
gosh it's still incredibly glad to
finally meet you you must be Johnny of
course you got B yeah I'm Johnny baby I
have an idea why don't you come up with
the topic and we could try discussing it
so clever
go ahead pick any topic I want to make
this night special shall I say even
magical haha okay right let's talk about
something I want to talk about Oh
insurance companies cuz that's my
passion
pterence companies really my father
worked at an insurance company what a
coincidental topic let you knew that
already in which kids have you been
stalking me I'm kidding of course huh
right so I remember pop I had some hard
times bringing the bacon on stressful
job long hours terrible bosses he's off
the more passed midnight on summers
terrible terrible job then he took a
decision that would change our lives
forever
he bought a lottery no way your dad won
the lottery also do you smell something
weird no dad won the lottery well not
really
well he went to talk to a gypsy which
desperately wanting to know the law
those winning numbers I can't blame him
we all wanted to win but oh me oh my
have we known the conscripts in exchange
for the winning number the Gypsy asked
for a bit of a high price we forced to
marry someone off a certain tribe why
you have such an active imagination
hahahahahaha thankfully we're way beyond
those times now right anyway which
offered the winning lottery number to my
dad only if our family protects reports
from an evil creature oh my god can you
imagine something more boring the kind
of danger is actually a mostly boring
also we didn't win the lottery it was
canceled last minute because the
organizer fell in love with the dog show
all right then okay I'm not going to
question that also I will point out this
is the same dating setting that we met
with the werewolf so and that is the
reason I'm now stuck as protector of
these floors
police is this a summer job so what are
you protecting it from all the which I
told you about she's big entrepreneur
she owns duck farm honeybee businesses
flower juice bar illusion search who's
terrified ah
some say lives in a dark dank came that
I may be a visited and warmed up a
little bit that I may be a visited and
had Rockets text with a werewolf in
that's been silent that's been other
faiths howling can low you into his mom
hell yeah I can the elders say that
touching its fur will turn you into
stone I was rock hard baby I think it
was Bill the other day said the creature
is a chick that sounds too far-fetched
she did all 110 woman baby for I kind of
totally hate talking about it this
creature keeps terrifying the squirrels
of forest - terrified Michael can you
imagine like squirrels are super cute
they don't serve that I just it dad
well sometimes they say that creature
killed doc thank God I don't have an
innuendo for that one no one sure if it
kills them just ponder for food but it's
just so cruel it only leaves the
feathers of those poor ducks dogs a gory
messy scene are you talking about Nicole
oh she's uh I called a friend what
you're friends with that creature I
can't see how you can we can be together
then the fates have been so cruel today
get out of my sight Friends of defenders
creatures the monsters themselves oh all
right well I got the poster those now
kind of cool see ah maybe she just
steals the ducks the police ruled that
out it's totally not stealing if a whole
families devoured well then there was no
evidence so what do you have to prove
sorry that was bad kind nervous right
fur you have no idea the crime seems
I've been around it
honey just settle down a bit I don't
want to ruin my date with such a big guy
by talking about my job
look Johnny I'm not sure if you already
noticed it but I'm still in front of you
duh yes Alan I met look um I have other
intentions with you like I totally want
to do stuff with you
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah baby
hell yeah so I'm here for our stuff and
things you know what I mean right
oh I know trust me I've done this like
once I know you know where we are I bet
you do you're so smart uh yellow of c1
and only place to find your middle self
yeah that's right we're at yellow us but
how did you know that I'm for sure I was
the first to bring you here I had a hot
steamy humid day dear few swipes to go
down to sound if he's the best faulty I
the hot steamy day baby
if Dan supposedly thought I was first my
moods blew up in you new duck
Johnny was transformed into a duck
yellow have a map app it's so well
prepared I can barely use the phone
since it's so brag I know maybe I can
get you to teach me someday huh right so
the job of mine you know guarding the
force is super stressful and it gives
like no time to experiment on stuff I
like I'll be your chairman I'll I'll be
your up here side flap baby I'll be here
I'll be your research and development
part Department I'm looking for you know
some privacy in the forest
that's why I brought you here I am I'm a
grad in practice in front of the mirror
huh I practice in from here every day
kind of like you and out here well
nobody can see is here then alone for a
while and I my fairy needs and I need
something someone big yeah that that's
me the big applier that's with the Colby
yeah that is you I'm saying hope you can
understand me yeah I got you on my idea
baby for me ha ha ha ha ha ha mine is
still embarrassing huh
so say things like that you dummy what
am i doing on your mind am i doing
something big
oh yeah oh yeah
[Music]
Rico Rico loco mega poco massage you
doing something with an object that
doesn't fit you I don't understand that
one I don't get it I have no idea where
you're talking about I'm gonna go with a
Rico Treecko logo mega poco massage
because at least that makes sense in it
Wow
sounds fun I know I'm gonna love
learning that massage let's go Johnny
oh hey boy night's still young brother
we can do even bigger than this well
alright then choose you're doing
something with this what are you saying
of course some clothes of yours wouldn't
fit talking about something naughty just
don't say things like that but I can try
them fitting anything Oh
guar oh wow is that going to summon a
certain someone so you're getting like
in the zone you almost sound like the
terrifying creatures of roams the forest
definitely approaching to your zone -
it's all moving so fast approach my zone
you're quick - I've been waiting for so
long I've been letting spores out all
the time do you like to smell I wanted
this night to be perfect so bad but you
know what I'm finally finally finally
3,000 and 18 years old Johnny I want to
try something that I couldn't before you
know as a young fairy maiden whoa whoa
you're only 30 18 I'm young I'm fierce
ha I'm not like too young for you right
technically I'm older though so I can't
go full throttles with Izzy wait I'm
gonna be your very first but of course
not I'm an experienced fairy if you know
what I mean hehe my very complete fairly
fairly complete I'm totally not a girl
anymore no I believe you I'll show you
how cucumber I can be I don't know I
don't know let's take it easy no knives
new for both of us okay by this point I
just want to go for it I'm in heating up
okay alright I thought this was
innuendos that was gonna lead somewhere
other than what this is obviously
leaning into I thought this was just
gonna be a whole bunch of jokes now all
my innuendos that I made previously
seemed a lot more dirty now that exactly
the reality of this let's go Johnny
ah okay so I get it like there's got to
be some way to bring the vias werewolf
lady into this because that's what this
is alluding to so there's got to be a
way to do that right these are my plans
run I'll show you some magic moves I've
been waiting all night to do so I wanted
totally wanted someone big to try this
it's so exciting
have you been smelling the spores I laid
for you tonight I've been wanting to
practice magic on humans for a while I'd
like you so so so so much and I'm so
happy I get to try my magic on you wait
a minute you're mine tonight so happy
totally mine we're going to get together
now
for working already so happy I'm gonna
fill you with my fairy dust okay I don't
Q human plaything that's so happy uh
Abby please Matt obviously Johnny got
shrunk by fairy magic for fitting
purposes win yeah I guess that's good
not Nabby oh please okay well I was only
one step away from it though oh hey I'm
gonna have yeah how you doing hey hey
let me let me put on my best link
impression for you all right one more
we're almost done we almost got this we
almost have absolutely kill duck well
that sounds good kill a hundred ducks
and get a prize though I don't know what
I'm doing with my life anymore but let's
do it let's get it I'd I I guess it's a
safe house of the day I don't understand
how does the date like the final date on
my list
it takes one hour 23 minutes and 10
seconds for a woman to determine whether
or not she wants to date a man again
a man decides in 15 minutes thereafter
just stupid jerk okay then good oh hello
it's Scott Walker
[Music]
oh so I need to kill a hundred ducks I
can do this if it seems awfully cruel I
would I would I want to kill these ducks
I mean obviously I want to take the
werewolf girl again
I think gamer skills engaged you think
you're a match for me huh I've matched
with stronger dates on linger than you
would ever see well no you do not oh
they're getting erratic now whoa hey
whoa hey whoa okay all right then this
is getting a little weird reality is
starting to break here not the reality
had anything to do with what we're
actually doing there but you know maybe
it could calm down for just a little bit
before I actually lose my goddamn mind
because I think winger just leads to
these places come on you come on you
come on you come on God don't even think
about what are you doing are you going
fast now huh viki's you're going fast
here your best huh being your best for
me oh we're going fast on her now okay
all right then I see how this is sick
you can escape my linger finger my
finger knows no limit what oh oh my god
oh my god oh my god oh my god oh my god
whoa holy crap okay all right they're
getting a little faster now what are you
doing wait oh okay all right then I
don't know
apparently I get a massage here after
this one I don't know why oh lucky
Oh ducky oh my god sorry I capped you to
death Frank Frank Frank
what okay Robin there's a thing yeah I
did it I did it I did it all I I I'm not
a horribly socially in that person maybe
I don't know could be but I did it I got
all my lingered a high I had weak tender
love with a jar of mayo I had I don't
remember who you were you're a werewolf
ah you
the internet day you're the mean girl
that was my favorite one jarmail that
was easily my favorite
oh yeah the alien what she was crazy on
Dorothy and pappu I use Navia oh it's
only night
okay so anyway that is all for mr.
Musashi I think there's some sort of
like DLC to this but I I'm not a
represent sure this game was actually a
lot of fun I had I'd quite a time going
through this so I hope you guys enjoyed
it too let me know what you think and if
there is DLC as it says in my social be
able to be really proud here so new
dates are signing up share mr. Musashi
and you'll see them soon so I hope to
see more stuff here I may play kind of
like playing booty pop again with that
loved watch also huniepop 2 is in
development do you guys know that that's
happening so thank you everybody so much
for watching and as always I will see
you in the next video bye bye
[Music]